we're totally on to you Hades you'd play
it off like you're as evil as they come
but we know what's really going on
you've got a score to settle with Mao
and you're embar can be used for good or
evil which side will you choose the fate
of our Don depends on it getting revenge
might be at the top of your list but
things might change once you realize
that mal is your daughter you might lose
your taste for revenge once you find out
who you're up against what if mal
doesn't even know who her father is
yeah we've got some solid evidence that
she's about to find out check out these
major signs that mal will find out that
Hades is her dad and descendants three
the first sign has everything to do with
mouths hair take a look at the beginning
of the new d3 official trailer when Vin
is proposing to now you'll see that
mouths hair is her signature purple
color as the trailer progresses mouths
hair starts to change when she is by
Aubrey's bedside her hair is almost as
blue as V's it's likely that this has to
do with Hades ember Hades forces open
the barrier and shoots a blue light from
his ember then we see mal duck and say
that she felt all of her powers slipping
away his mouse hair start changing after
Hades attacked her with his blue ember
but then why were Ben Carlos and Jay not
affected when they got knocked over by
the blast we think it's because Hades is
Mel's dad that means that mal would have
a stronger reaction to his ember turning
her hair blue the first encounter
between Mel and Hades it's in his glare
you can see that Mouse hair is purple
but at the end of the trailer Mouse hair
is bluer than ever
this is a very good indicator that mal
is feeling a father-daughter bond with
the Lord of the underworld now let's go
back to the official trailer for another
clue if you freeze it right before Hades
grabs Mel's hand you'll see something
interesting mal is trying to steal Hades
ember from the table next to him and she
totally gets busted we don't know
exactly what mal and Hades are talking
about in his lair but Hades looks pretty
ticked off this could be the moment when
now discovers that Hades is her dad
however we think this discovery won't
happen until later in the movie consider
this it's entirely possible that matey's
is also unaware that Meryl is his
daughter so the two of them could be
completely in the dark about each
other's existence until d3 here's why
this is a major possibility when mal and
her crew lead the Isle
Hades breaks through the barrier and
attacks
mal and her friends with his Ember he
drains mal of all her powers now what
kind of father would knowingly do that
to his own daughter
even if he is a villain on the Isle
that's a pretty despicable move and why
would mal have to sneak around and steal
her father's ember couldn't she just ask
to borrow it for a hot second this leads
us to believe that man doesn't know that
Hades is her dad and Hades is absolutely
clueless that mal is his daughter so how
did they discover the truth about each
other well there's a certain pink
princess who's about to change
everything for mal and Hades from the
trailers we know that Hades somehow gets
off the Isle
he appears over sleeping Audrey waving
his blue amber above her bed the
menacing look on his face makes us
believe that Hades has cast an evil
spell on her for what if he actually is
protecting now and are done if he gets
off the Isle and discovers that Myles
hair is turning blue like her dad's hair
he may realize who she is then mal and
hoodies join forces to overpower Audrey
together they reverse the evil spells at
Audrey cast on the kingdom of auradon
with Maleficent scepter additionally we
know that Mouse powers have been drained
however at the end of the official
trailer Mouse powers are back with a
vengeance her eyes turn green purple
smoke engulfs her and the next thing you
know she is breathing fire if you zoom
in you'll see that the maggin is
shooting flames at a figure on top of
the castle booth and the figure is
holding a glowing green sector
so how did mal get her powers back for
this ultimate battle against Audrey we
think it was Hades you guys
Hades might realize his love for his
daughter and use his Ember to restore
her powers after she takes out Audrey
mal and her dad used the Ember to
restore our deen to its original state
then Hades gets a free pass off the Isle
for his contribution to good if all this
plays out the way we think now will be
the luckiest villain kid ever she will
actually have a loving parent that's a
huge deal since there's a total shortage
of caring parents among the villain kids
maybe mouths relationship with her dad
will encourage other villain parents to
change their ways this could be the
revolution the Isle has been waiting for
if you seal the families you heal the
world what do you guys think if you
think Hades will become good when Mao
discovers he is her dad
[Music]
if so leave a purple devil and blue
heart emoji in the comments hit that
subscribe button so you never miss our
descendants three videos and be sure to
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching the things see you next
time
[Music]